[Music]
all right ernesto
ernesto uh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up i grew up in south
central
or south l.a and tell me about your
your childhood you had both your parents
when you were young uh no i don't know
my dad
um my mom was a sole provider
um i was raised by my grandmother
basically
um and that was solely because my mother
had to always be at work
she had to be at work for like six in
the morning
so she would leave at like 4 30 to get
there on time and then
when she got home usually after dark so
my grandmother basically saw me up to
school
and received me when i came home how
would you describe your childhood
um i was sheltered for most of my
childhood um
i was i was sheltered so i was uh naive
you know i would look out the window see
all the kids in there but playing and
you know i asked my mom can i go play
she'd tell me no but she never gave me a
reason
um you know i was an only child then
my mother's only child so i don't know
if there's anything to do with it but uh
yeah i was uh sheltered she was
overprotective
and you've been married before no
no kids no so you like to go down to uh
some of the neighborhoods and pick up
some of the girls that work the streets
yes
how long has that been going on um
off and on i'd say maybe 15 years
20 closer to 20.
and you'll take the girls to a hotel or
a hotel yeah
and you have regular girls that you'll
frequent or you change that
well as they say variety is the spice of
life so uh
there's a lot to choose from down there
oh yeah that's why i couldn't understand
uh one thing i couldn't understand when
i was young is uh
you supposed to marry one woman getting
still
every woman has their uh individual
characteristics traits that are
attractive so
sort of hard to pick just one yeah
do you do you go which street do you
usually go to your role figure
yeah figaro has a huge selection of
beautiful ladies very large
there's something for everybody down
there
and it's an interesting street because
it like
after around 10 11 like around midnight
you'll have
cars lined up yeah like so many cars
lined up like a drive-through
yeah it looks like a drive-through
and you know so many girls so many guys
looking i mean
i don't know how much how many of the
girls are actually getting picked up but
it's
it's an interesting phenomenon true some
some
some men just uh
drive around just to see the women i
just look at that yeah just look at them
it's a turn on like this everyone has
their own
you know vice or what have you
and what kind of things have you seen
you had some crazy experiences
uh yeah i mean pretty much uh
you know everything from being uh
robbed um
[Music]
you know uh you know well yeah rob
basically
um yeah some of the girls that's that's
their specialties yeah
yeah and i don't know how she did it you
know because
maybe her feet or something i don't know
you know but uh
yeah it was uh it was odd
um you know because i had my money
tucked in my shoe
so when i take my shoes off but she
never got off the bed
so you know i don't understand how but
hey
you know these girls are pros yeah true
you ever been arrested for anything uh
yeah i was arrested i've been arrested
for uh
um burglary but like
not solicitation no nothing related to
this
no wow that's it
possession yeah no but i'm just talking
in terms of
the girls working the street what do you
um
do you do you enjoy the freedom yeah
definitely and uh i tried relationships
and uh
you know it's too too much of a headache
too many expectations once once it's
official it's like you have to do this
you have to do that
and i guess you could say i have an uh
an affinity for non-conformity uh you
know
so i don't i guess i don't like to be
told what to do
yeah i mean you know where are drugs a
part of your
life uh yeah they were before for a
while
i know you know i don't
i take a step back you know sometimes
because i go so far and
i mess up so much money and uh you know
i say okay you know you got to get it
together
uh but then you know i'd stay clean i've
been through about drug programs
uh outpatient inpatient
you know the whole deal
but i mean obviously there was uh
underlying uh
issues that you know they say uh
we take we take the drug the drug is not
the issue that
we take the drugs to resolve our resolve
resolve our issue whatever maybe we know
whether it be to forget about it or
cope with it and deal with it so uh
you know i think my main thing was uh
i didn't know my father you know and i
just couldn't understand how
you you you know regardless of what the
situation or circumstance was
between you and my mother you know has
nothing to do with me
you know i'm your seed how could you not
look for you know
your seat you know and so i don't know i
think that that
probably paid played a big role in
me making some other life choices
and like i said my mother was an only
child so
uh i don't have any aunts uncles cousins
you know i didn't have any positive male
role models per se
uh growing up so uh
uh yeah once i got a taste of freedom
you know it kind of broke wide
you know and so being out in the streets
you know what's out in the streets
pimps players hustlers no thugs
you know so those were like my male
role models i guess you could say
[Music]
so uh yeah so i mean you're
because of the childhood experiences you
had
the commitment of a marriage or
something like that might
might not be your your forte uh
i mean i mean i i would like to be
married you know
um because that's the ideal thing you
know have a family and
buy a home and so forth and so on uh
i mean i would like to settle down you
know um
that's part of the reasons why i don't
have any children you know
uh you know everyone everyone has their
issues no one's perfect including myself
of course
and uh i don't think i found anyone to
where
even if we have our differences she
won't play pawn with my kids you know
you can't see your son because you won't
have sex with me you can't see your
daughter because you won't give me money
you know because that's important to me
you know because my father wasn't there
for me so
like the relationships i've been in they
usually already have children
so i try to be a constant in their life
you know i tell them you know
i'm not your father but you know uh you
can still lean on me whatever it is you
need
and uh you know the interesting part is
that um
i still keep in touch with most of my
ex's children you know i call them
and wish them happy birthday and they
really appreciate it you know they say
wow my own father doesn't
call me on my birthday you know and so
you know that kind of hits home with me
as far as you know kids children
whatever
uh so yeah i mean i i hope to be married
do you ever find yourself developing
stronger feelings for any of the girls
that you pick up
yeah yeah i'm i'm genuinely a caring
person so
um you know i i tried to
befriend them i guess you could say you
know so it's not so much like a
business transaction you know i you know
i
and i think i'm just generally concerned
for for people in general so
you know i i try to get to know them and
see you know what led them to
pretty much like what you're doing you
know what led them to become a
prostitute and uh
nine times out of ten uh the constant uh
variable
in their stories is that uh they were
abused at home you know at a very early
age by uh
whether it be a parent whether it be you
know a relative or
a neighbor or whatever the case may be
it's pretty much like
100 percent of the time yeah pretty much
yeah i've been i've learned that over
the years
um yeah either either they were abused
or abandoned one of the two
you know so they were in foster foster
system and
nine times out of ten you're going to
get abused in the foster system you know
whether it be
physical abuse sexual abuse you know it
all plays a part especially when you're
at a young age it affects you and i
think you know
if you don't get treatment for you know
therapy it uh
you know it stays with you yeah
you know i've interviewed a few hundred
i think now these girls and it's like
sometimes
your heart just opens up and you you
want to save them you want to help them
you want to do something for them and
i don't know that i don't know that's
even possible sometimes yeah
uh yeah i mean you know i try to be an
optimist you know and some of the
stories that i've heard
from some of the women it's like wow you
know
like it makes me feel like i haven't
gone through anything you know when they
tell me their stories it's like
wow you know you really survived that
and you're still here and you're still
through a lot
yeah been through a lot i was like you
know no i i think i'll be
eternally hopeful that someday
you know i'll save somebody or help
somebody in some way that makes a real
difference true
but they seem to be resistant to it as
well it's almost like they're so
ingrained in this
yeah low self-worth yeah that this
career
requires true i think i think once you
once you uh
once you once you've been through so
much it's like one thing after another
it's like you expect
you know that's what you come to expect
so you why even try to pick myself
up when something negative is going to
happen anyway every time i do
you know which has kind of been my life
story as well you know i you know
um it's like when i i tried to uh
break away from the drugs and and and
street life is like uh
i'll take i'll get a job i'll take two
steps forward and then
you know something in life you know a
life hurdle i guess you would call it
well make me stumble and i you know fall
back two steps
i'll take make one step forward and two
steps back because they say you know
make progress with you
so you know it's like man you know
what's the sense of
you know continuing to try it's like you
know
you know and they say your life is
predestined you know
i i don't i don't know how true that is
i think it's it it uh
has to do with a lot of your choices but
then your choices come from
how you were raised where you were
raised you know your environment is part
of
who you become yeah so you know
[Music]
yeah yeah what i suspect
is the abuse that we experience as
children
or like let's take some of the girls
that work the streets the
the the abuse the lack of love the
disrespect that they
endured as children become something
that they
they look for as adults they say it has
a standard because you know that's an
interesting point because
i noticed you know when i tried to like
uh help i guess you could say yeah to
whatever extent
you know uh it's like they push you away
you know
if you're nice to them they they push
they don't want that
they don't know how to react to that
because no one's ever been yeah and so
it's like yeah i'm like you know like
what's wrong but i you know i had to
come to the realization that
you know once you went through so much
you know and then they probably hadn't
been
tricked you know someone came to them in
in
in that fashion as a as if they were
wanting to help them and then it wound
up being
something completely opposite well i i
i think that that the only thing that
works for an
adult who's been abused as a child is
something very similar to that
relationship that they were abused in
when they were young
so so this working the streets and being
treated like just being used by everyone
right does does the trick nicely for
them
that's that's my suspicion yeah because
you know they say they might want a
prince charming to come and save them
but
when he does when he shows up they don't
know what to do with it they
they well i think it comes along with
the territory because
you know when you live in the street or
whether you live in the street or you
have
an apartment or whatever uh you know you
you you have to be aware of everyone so
uh you can't be nice to to anyone no you
can't trust anyone
you can't trust anyone you can't so i
mean that's to be expected
you know i have i have some uh some
friends that i grew up with they you
know
i saw him prostitute one day i tried to
talk to her and
i was like well you know what's the
issue she was like there is no issue
i enjoy sex and and i'm when i was
doing boyfriends and and so forth i was
having sex
but i was still uh i still had needs i
still had you know
uh bills and so you know
someone told me well if you're gonna
[ __ ] why you might as well get paid wipe
up for free
you know because it's i mean you know
stole this profession
uh i don't know if that's anything to do
with it but uh yeah so they
they they took that upon as their as
their
motto you know and so
i don't know yeah it's it's it's an
interesting subculture here
true true hello ernesto thank you for
coming in and talking with me
thank you for having me mark be careful
absolutely
don't get robbed again yeah i kind of
learned my lesson
you know from that all right thank you
very much
thank you
you